new reports paint a devastating picture
of the worsening crisis on our southern
border filings from june show that
officials encountered more than 200 000
illegals for the fourth straight month
and even more disturbing than that 56 of
those apprehended this year
had been flagged on the terrorist
screening database senator ron johnson
just returned from touring the epicenter
of the crisis in the rio grande valley
and he joins us now senator great to
have you this morning thank you
good morning let's dive into that number
56 on the terror watch list i believe uh
that number doesn't just exceed where we
were earlier this year month by month
but the total last year it's
however it is it's an astounding number
senator what can you tell us about these
56 individuals i don't know if there's
any more information out there but what
type of individuals are on the watches
getting flagged and then we're now
encountering at the southern border
well what i would say is that's probably
just the tip of the iceberg those are
the people that we've encountered
that we don't even call it apprehensions
anymore since the bite administration
began we've encountered more than three
million people crossing the border
illegally that's over six thousand
people a day the last four months it's
been over seven 000 people a day
but again those are the people we
encounter uh there's a large number of
people that they call them known or
unknown godaways and those are that
really represents the real national
security threat are people that again
we're so overwhelmed by the
apprehensions that there creates
openings for deadly drugs as well as
a very unsavory characters coming from
over 150 nations now is what we've
encountered over 150 nations so we have
a completely open border
this administration is oblivious to it
they won't even admit it's a problem uh
president biden vice president harris
haven't even been to the border uh but
one thing i have to point out it's
important for people to realize the
southwest border is 100 controlled on
the mexican side of the border by the
drug cartels by the human trafficking
cartels it's about an 18 billion dollar
business by a back of the envelope
calculation from one of our briefings 18
billion dollars and that just accounts
for the people we've encountered
so this is we're we're pumping you know
there's billions of dollars being pumped
into these organizations
being facilitated this multi-billion
dollar business model is being
facilitated by president biden's open
border policy it's sick and the human
depredations i wish i could convey to
your listeners how profoundly disturbing
it is to go there and encounter for
example a six and seven year old girl
unaccompanied all they have is their
birth certificate and a phone number and
an address of somebody they know in the
us if they lose that
what happens to them and you know bill
mclugan is doing a great job reporting
he was at the border with us told us
that a few few weeks or a few months
before that very spot
of similarly young girls had just been
raped
and they were being given medical
tensions by border and customs patrol
this
the the human depredations the drug
trafficking the human trafficking the
sex slaves caused by this illegal flow
that needs to be highlighted but again
other than fox news a few other uh
outlets the mainstream media is not down
there they're covering up for joe biden
they're complicit in this they are
corrupt
well speaking of well said by the way
and thank you for going there i wish
administration officials would actually
go
talk about it of course they won't so
you are thank you for doing that you've
also been all over the story speaking of
not telling the story of hunter biden
and that story was suppressed we know uh
by social media against the new york
post well now the new york post has
another uh data point and you followed
this as close as anybody here's a
portion of what they've now learned in
looking at the laptop
hunter biden often would huddle with his
dad in the days or even minutes after
high profile meetings
between february 15th and 18th 2012
hunter biden was wined and dined by
billionaire oligarchs in moscow
including one now wanted for murder four
days after his return hunter biden met
with vice president biden again
at the naval observatory it goes on with
example after example
yet joe bidens continues to say he knew
nothing senator
well the media continues to cover up for
him uh senator grassley and i we tried
to warn americans that we issued our
report in september of 2020 to show the
vast web of foreign french entanglements
the corruption of biden inc but the
mainstream media not only ignored it
they accused us of soliciting dissenting
russian disinformation and of course we
had 50 intelligence officials uh also
perform their own intelligence or their
information operation as they said that
that's
the hunter
laptop
was basically a russian information
operation so it's been covered up it
shows the complicity and corruption of
not only the news media but certain
elements within our federal law
enforcement our federal agencies this is
a huge scandal but the the mainstream
media is coming up and we know now
conclusively because the the laptop is
such a treasure show of information that
president biden was lying to us as a
candidate he continues to lie the
mainstream media cover up for him
if republicans take back control of the
house i think hunter biden should be
expecting a subpoena so more information
to come in this episode senator ron
johnson thank you so much for joining us
thank you sir have a good day
you too i'm steve ducey i'm brian
kilmeade and i'm ainslie earhart and
click here to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis